l'été dernier
[Musique]
tout ça en mémoire parce qu'on ne sait
jamais si c'est la dernière fois qu'on
voit un endroit
pour une personne
je savais qu'un jour ou l'autre je
perdrai Suzana ce que je ne savais pas
c'est que je finirais par tous les
perdre je devrais être en train de fêter
mon diplôme avec Conrad et Jérémy les
mecs veulent même plus répondre à mes
messages parce que tu as foutu un
immense merdier
je suis contente
[Musique]
et ensuite tu es sorti avec mon frère et
tout le monde espérer que tu fasses
comme si tout allait bien alors que
c'était pas le cas je suis vraiment
désolé j'étais beaucoup trop à fond je
voulais être là pour Conrad j'aurais dû
être là pour toi aussi
[Musique]
je suis là c'est parce que la maison
vient d'être mise en vente comment ça la
maison est en vente
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ici
[Musique]
et elle manque énormément à ces garçons
cet endroit est la perte de leur mère
sont par conséquent liés je voulais te
demander si tu serais d'accord pour te
rétracter de la vente désolé mais je
choisis de la mettre en vente
je pensais qu'en perdant Susanna on
avait perdu la magie de cousine pour
toujours mais je peux peut-être trouver
un moyen de la ramener
[Musique]
c'est cool de voir que bélier toi vous
vous êtes réconcilié salut manquait être
ami avec toi
l'impression que tout le monde nous
lâche et qui a plus que la maison qui
nous relie on lâchera pas on va trouver
une solution
je suis pour moi
j'adore c'est bon ça
[Musique]
ERAI pas à t'oublier je t'assure il n'y
a plus aucun sentiment entre
Conrad et toi
quand j'imaginais l'avenir
[Musique]
c'était toujours le même garçon
est incertain
mais il m'appartient
[Musique]